we have a rare look now inside a medical
clinic on the front lines in Ukraine
facing the devastating aftermath of
those controversial cluster bombs Russia
has been using them and the U.S now
plans to send them to Ukraine's Army as
well Charlie dagada saw the very real
human effect these weapons can have and
he saw it up close at an undisclosed
location in eastern Ukraine and we do
warn you as we often do this report
contains disturbing images
coffee at this shell of a clinic near
the front lines there is no telling what
the day will bring for Dr Alexi and his
skeleton staff this is a stabilization
Clinic the first stop for wounded
soldiers and civilians with one primary
mission
we stabilize so with their heart
failures or blood losses he says we
bring the patient back to life and we
take them further down the evacuation
line
so they survived long enough to reach
better equipped hospitals the hours-long
journey further away from the constant
risk of Russian bombardment
there are explosions off in the distance
but then something much closer
there's a sudden urgency take someone
with you and go check it out Dr Alexi
orders
secondary explosions ring out weary
soldiers seem to know exactly what's
happening
first of the injured arrive
soldiers more Gravely wounded
but then we watched as the civilian
started coming
begging for help
some unable to speak at all
about 20 minutes after we arrive there's
this huge explosion not more than two or
three hundred yards away and ever since
it's been this steady flow of wounded
soldiers and civilians alike
we lost count of the number of people
rushed through the doors but it became
clear this was an attack on a
residential neighborhood
we have a cardiac arrest shelter medic
heart stopped for two minutes they're
struggling to find room
let's start compressions now
the overwhelm Clinic has quickly become
a battlefield triage in the chaos life
and death decisions between who may make
it
and who will not
this is the harsh reality of War
shrapnel wounds head injuries chest
injuries limbs clamped with tourniquets
to stop patients from bleeding to death
wounds consistent with cluster bombs Dr
Alexi tells us because you're of your
experience can you be sure those
injuries were from a cluster bomb
yes they're used by the enemy a lot it's
not the first time and not the last
we saw some of those horrific injuries
is it fair to say that if they weren't
treated here first they might not have
made it to the next Hospital
yes they wouldn't have made it he says
blood loss is enormous in those injuries
the first thing is to put tourniquets on
did you lose some people today too
attack yes it's a war he says people die
despite the trauma he says there's no
time to be tired he'll rest after the
war do you ever get angry
for me anger is like a motivating force
he says I just point it in the right
direction
for CBS mornings Charlie dagada in
eastern Ukraine
you hear these denials from Russia about
how they don't Target civilians pouring
in right after explosions in the not too
distant uh future so I it's we we say
disturbing images we say it often that
really lived hard to see people possibly
dying right before your eyes yeah it's
tough to watch but necessary reminder of
what is going on